همم راينا ايضا من خلال هذه الصور مجموعه
من القوات الامنيه تتجه الى جهه
المتظاهرين هل تم استدعاء المزيد من القوى
الامنيه كيف هو الوضع والمعلومات المتوفره
لديك
والتعزيزات الامنيه الموجوده على الارض
يه في هذه القضيه ايضا كان هناك المدعي
العام في باريس كان يتواجد في هذه المنطقه
واا بعض التصريحات لكن تم استخدام تعزيزات
اضافيه بسبب التجمع الذي احدثه اشخاص في
محيط المنطقه وكذلك لحمايه المواقع التي
همم
في قربها هذا الاعتداء اليوم هذه تصريحات
كانت من وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيراننا
قبل قليل قال ان التعزيزات الامنيه او
سيتم رفع التحديثات الامنيه في هذه
المنطقه وخصوصا امام المركز الثقافه
الكردي الذي وقع امامه هذا الحادث
بالاضافه الى الوحدات الدبلوماسيه لتركيا
في عدد من الشوارع في العاصمه باريس
التعديلات ما زالت همم تتواصل في هذه
المنطقه وربما ايضا قد ترسل تعزيزات اخرى
لمكافحه من قوات مكافحه الشباب للسيطره
على الوضع اكثر واا فتح المجال امام
التحقيقات امام